je suis beaucoup d'émotion franchement
ya appelé d'émotion de joie de stress
encore on se relâche un peu poussé c'est
vraiment avec joie que je vais
représenter la martinique la femme ronde
en tout cas de la marche mais j'ai je me
suis donné à fond en tout cas pour y
arriver et donc je suis maintenant que
je sois la miss qu'est-ce qui a fait la
prudence je pense que c'est ma
personnalité
parce que je me donne à fond quand je me
donne à fond c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment mon référent c'est sûr que je
ne crois pas qu un parti vert
eh bien ça représentait déjà le fait que
je veux que je m'assure en tout cas que
je représente la femme ronde et pour moi
c'est une joie en tout cas d'être
détruit lui ne pouvait quand même quand
elle décroît aujourd'hui la question qui
tue alors la question c'est est est ce
que je dis mais devons-nous dénuder pour
être mises en valeur en tout cas et je
pense que non je pense que non puisque
les femmes au plusieurs projets peuvent
elles peuvent se mettre en valeur avec
des coiffures avec le maquillage
voilà